hey guys justin here with the gamespot
news update valva said previously of
those are going to be a GDC with a steam
controller and some steam machines but
they haven't talked about until today is
a steam VR project their first entry
into the virtual reality space valve
announced today that at GDC and San
Francisco they'll be demoing the refined
steam controller new living room devices
and a previously unannounced steam VR
hardware system currently there are
several virtual reality systems being
developed for console and PC gaming
including the long and development
oculus rift Sony's project Morpheus and
a VR platform from razor however the
only device is currently available in a
consumer ready version are for mobile in
its statement valve rope with the
introduction of steam VR hardware valve
is actively seeking VR content creators
they ask publishers and developers
interested in the new hardware to come
demo the system at the moscone center in
san francisco GDC is just around the
corner so stay tuned to gamespot com /
news for even more news about steam VR
and other GDC announcements